this week on quadriga Bundeswehr
missions is the military ready training
the Kurds in northern Iraq deliveries of
aid to Ebola stricken West Africa just
two examples of Germany's Armed Forces
being sent to crisis zones around the
world but a government commissioned
report published this week says they do
not have the equipment they need
large procurement projects are being
delivered years late and often millions
of euros over budget the result the
Bundeswehr has to rely on old equipment
which needs frequent maintenance and
often cannot be used at all why is
Germany's military not fully operational
and can it fulfill its NATO obligations
your host this week le asla hello and
welcome to a new edition of quadriga
well you've just heard the question is
Germany's military operational and ready
that is the question we want to get to
the bottom of on today show and of
course with all the crises going on
right now in the world it is a very
vital question and to answer that I have
invited three experts today all who've
been following this story very closely
very welcome to johannes light Rosa who
is a berlin correspondent for the german
newspaper Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung
he's been with the newspaper since 1988
and served previously as the papers
London correspondent also very warm
welcome to Judy Dempsey who is senior
associate at carnagie Europe and the
editor-in-chief of the blog strategic
Europe previously she reported for the
International Herald Tribune the
economists and the Financial Times and
last but not least Alison snail who has
the New York Times Bureau here in Berlin
as deputy for an editor at the New York
Times she organized much of the papers
coverage of the Iraq war and of course
she was also formerly executive editor
at the Herald Tribune very warm welcome
to you all you wanna slide toys let's
get right to it a leak parliamentary
report detailed the rather dismal state
of the Germans military hardware
now you've covered German politics for a
very long time including the military
that this report surprised you not in
the least I think it didn't even
surprised the Defence Minister mrs. von
der Leyen because when she presented it
in the end she said you could say it's
all same old
same old with many of these things
before and it's all about the new
weapons and technology the German
military has been waiting for for many
many years now and as your film said
just now it is because we have to use
the old stuff so many years longer that
there are frequent breakdowns and things
occurring that shouldn't happen so no
surprise says you're on a slight oh is
that Judy what about you actually I was
surprised that it was published actually
although von der Leyen the Minister of
Defense you wanted to do this for two
reasons that she's inherited a complete
mess in the German armed forces there's
been talk about reform yes they got rid
of conscription but that wasn't
accompanied by fundamental structural
reforms weapons procurement training and
modernizing the entire Armed Forces so
in that sense was very clever of her to
commissioned an independent report to
finally explain to the German public and
make successful what is our army for and
indeed the German military is not so
much in the headlines this is one of the
rare occasions where we actually talk
about and not just on the show but also
in the papers and the articles here that
you are right house and smell you've
written an article about the the rather
dismal state of Germany's military
hardware and now as a non German who is
covering Germany though is that
something that took you by surprise well
no because I have actually followed
German affairs for a long time and I
think it's been obvious to everybody
that the Bundeswehr has never had the
sort of priority in this society for
understandable reasons that it has say
that Armed Forces have been say Britain
or France so there's a difficulty of
commanding resources of commanding
attention but what's happening now it's
not so much that the state of the
military is new the context is new we
are in the middle of several crises
Germany has is in the middle of a debate
about how much to sort of step up its
presence on the international stage and
these two things have got therefore come
together and I think Judy is absolutely
right that Fonda Lyon wanted to surface
all of this presumably with the backing
of the Chancellor so that they could
start to finally tackle because if you
are going to have a more active role on
the international stage
you've got to have the tools and before
we get into much more detail about what
to do with this report and the
consequences let's have a quick look at
what is what the report actually has
found out let's have a quick look the
first airbus a400m transport plane is
expected to be ready next month five
years behind schedule but the plane it
is meant to replace the c-160 Transall
has been in service for 50 years and is
no longer reliable problems with the
aircraft recently caused an embarrassing
delay in a transport of weapons from
Germany to the Kurds in northern Iraq
with a puma tank it's the same story
technical problems late delivery and the
price tag keeps on rising meanwhile much
of the Bundeswehr existing equipment is
not usable at all less than a third of
its Tiger combat helicopters are
operational and out of 109 euro fighter
aircraft only 42 are ready for action
well Johannes this report cannot please
you cannot please anyone only a fraction
of Germany's helicopter submarines and
tanks are fit to be deployed this is
what the report says
you still say you're you're not are you
you're not surprised you say but are you
at least satisfactory that's that's
clear if you go into these details which
we don't want to do too much you will
find different reasons for any kind of
weapon why it's not ready for instance
the helicopters were first conceived in
in the ending days of the Cold War when
they were meant to tank Russian to
attack Russian tanks coming over the
northern German planes then they they
have been ordered in the 19th so that's
20 years back things have developed
since so the military always came back
to the planners and said look we have to
change things the planners changed
things
the helicopters were not ready then then
we got this huge mission anything the
German military cannot keep up to date
with technology I would know the German
military part the industry then has to
to deliver again and to make new plans
and that takes time so I think there's
takes two to tango here as well there is
the industry on one side and the
military on the other and what happened
in the end we have this long lasting
mission in Afghanistan and they brought
these helicopters in there at the very
end and for that they had to be changed
again so they started to kind of
cannibalize they had got 20 by then and
to fit out eight of them properly they
ripped the others of spare parts and
send them to Afghanistan to make them
work there so that's what you end up
with when you change things too often
and I think that's one of the
conclusions of this report we have to to
get rid of standards somehow to make
things work quicker I think there's a
very interesting point and Germany is no
exception there's always ambiguities
between industry the military in
industry complex and the Armed Forces
you see this in France you see this
particularly the United States and in
Great Britain and all the conflicts you
know who to buy from the kind of lobbies
and so on so maybe you're all you're oh
there's the Justice never sufficient
transparency and so Fonda line was
to deal with this the other aspect which
and in defense of the defense ministry
is that the enormous wear and tear of
equipment in the borne Afghanistan
helicopters were used for three months
full of dust had to go back and so they
had the maintenance charges were huge on
the one hand on the other hand the
German Bundeswehr the soldiers in Nath's
Kansas Afghanistan the German soldiers
complained about getting enough decent
equipment enough protection enough
literally and equipment to look after
them and saw what has happened money was
diverted from the budget to give them
extra protection and what happened
not enough money for spare parts by the
way I mean they all of all the things
they needed in their combat mission they
got very quickly so can be done which
it's a split picture it's basically I'd
really do come back to this question of
context and the fact is that there's
still a reluctance in this society to
deploy German force in any way or to
think of that as part one of the kind of
equal tools of diplomacy and foreign
policy you see there's a relation
between public opinion and the dismal
state of the German Bundesrat
in a very indirect way I mean I'm not
saying oh well Germans don't think
enough about it so therefore they don't
have but it does you know it's
instructive that the Defense Ministry in
this I think in the Bundesliga bleak
they've been seventeen defence ministers
there have been far fewer Chancellor's
only one of the defence ministers Helmut
Schmidt has ever gone on to become
Chancellor this is not an easy job in
German politics and fun de Lyonne seems
to have some backing from the
Chancellery to really try to sort it out
she has a reputation as being brisk and
businesslike she's obviously trying to
use that reputation
absolutely so I mean it was quite
interesting to watch her performance in
Parliament yesterday I thought because
it was actually pretty low-key it was
just very matter-of-fact but the chamber
was not very full at all there were far
more people school pupils and others in
the gallery than there were actual
deputies for their for their debate
let's pick up understanding of the
German Bundeswehr in German society
as you think that the cuts and
underinvestment that the German military
has had to endure over the decades
absolutely right if you look at recent
recent polls should we go and help the
fight against is in Iraq or Syria you'll
find the majority the same well maybe
not and I think it's a big task for
politicians in Germany to make aware the
the international responsibility this
country has got this debate has started
a year ago and not started for the first
time we have done this ten years ago as
well I mean this report could not have
come at a worse time because this is the
year where leading German politicians
including defense ministers Olaf on the
line has declared that Germany is ready
and willing to play a greater role in
world affairs to underpin this because
as Alison said you can't you can't I
mean it's a real catch phrase now
Germany must assume greater
responsibility but you know it really
what does this mean and it responsible
for humanitarian affairs for delivering
weapons and Germany does an awful lot of
this I would but also to be seriously
involved in crisis management from
conflicts so you have to have the hard
hard tools and the soft power tools to
under to underpin what is emerging as a
new intellectual philosophical
discussion of but Germany's
responsibilities by the way this didn't
start this started in 1999 when the
red-green coalition was in and when you
had your first degree in foreign
minister yashka Fisher he started the
debate and that was completely snuffed
out a friend a friend the center when
the left when the left-right coalition
came in a 2005 so since you were back to
2020 1999 the role of Germany as a
security provider but this year Ellison
all president Guk owes enough on the
line
foreign minister Steinmeier they've all
made a point that Germany is ready and
willing to play sport is there a
discrepancy between ambition and
capability in well I mean I think
there's a discrepancy perhaps between
ambition and popular will and obviously
to some extent all these difficulties do
mount up and
illustrate perhaps we need a sort of
greater debate about where do we put our
resources and I think I'm in a friend
defense expert I know made a good point
the other day too which is it's much
easier for Fonda Lyon to say oh yes well
enter this thing by transporting
something to Mali or to Central African
Republic because it's much easier for
the German public to say oh well
military planes are going somewhere and
you're good for a good purpose than to
say we're deploying a unit of
paratroopers somewhere huh what you know
German boots on the ground and a
dangerous situation we're not sure about
that but I would want to say it's not
that we would not think we we don't want
to be embedded in a fire or strangling
or coming into a combat or getting home
casualties it's it's more than that
first of all we don't regard the army as
a as a sovereign to love our foreign
policy and that's the huge difference to
France Britain and the United States we
would never if we had got Falkland
Islands we would never have went there
on our own I mean not a problem but the
situation it's a Parliament's army it's
an army that can only be deployed with
the specific approval of Parliament yeah
and then that there has always to be an
international course regarding a
situation or crisis where we then could
say okay we we want to be part of this
international effort but we would not
there's no national will to say look we
have to solve this now by military means
because there's no other option and and
that's that's very different from other
Western countries interesting thing is
that this debate is happening as a time
pendous the demilitarization of the
armed forces across many of the European
countries the British Armed Forces
budget has been totally decimated
they provide only two f-16 fighters to
the u.s. Coalition of the Willing
against is the de mer the morale in the
in the armed forces in Britain is very
very low as it is in France now the
Dutch are cutting back why and it's not
just the economy there's a war weariness
after Iraq after
Afghanistan after the botched mission in
Libya and and also much more
fundamentally there's a an unspoken
debate is the use of force effective
enough and we have seen this fall out in
in Afghanistan especially in Iraq and
Libya and this is quote a kind of
underlying questioning that now the
military is asking not just in Germany
but particularly in Britain and around
someone mood I mean you're not gonna
negotiate with Isis here are you you
can't I mean this is this is the German
dilemma by the way it's a dilemma for
the United States that it's a non-state
actor and there are more more non-state
actors now coming coming into the fourth
this is extremely difficult in your
honest is Germany willing willing we
know but is it ready to meet its NATO
obligations oh well yes and no it is
willing to to contribute to the fight
against the the Islamic terrorists with
the Germans have been quite quick in
deploying weapons and military aid for
the Kurdish fighters in the north of
Iraq Syria is a different thing for us
again there are constitutional drawbacks
and matters to rest the elephant in the
room we haven't talked about yet is
Vladimir Putin and Russia and if you ask
are we ready to meet our obligations in
the case that NATO is attacked military
I would say no but this is this is the
Armageddon I mean this is this is
bringing the Cold War back and fighting
a hot war and then you can can ask they
are on the paper they are listed 60 or
80 euro fighters we would have to deploy
within 180 days and we wouldn't match
this target at the moment well what is
the consequence then of this report
Ellison appear at the end of the day
increase in military spending well I
think that's an interesting point
because for the first time in many years
there really is a discussion about
increasing military spending so if that
is one of the things that von der Leyen
and the government in general wanted to
surface they've succeeded let's be
specific of what we're talking about
currently
Germany spends 1.3 percent of its GDP in
numbers 33 billion euro NATO target is 2
percent so Germany Falls way short
right as do most other countries I mean
I think it's better 3 countries that are
meeting their targets so it's not as if
Germany doesn't have plenty of company
here but because it's an important
country and obviously you know it means
a lot of money and the one point the 2
percent of GDP which nature sets the
benchmark it's sort of it's academic
it's really it's it's what you spend the
money on and as it is the the members of
NATO does duplication there is not
enough there's hardly any sharing and
pooling to use the word and some tanks
some have models of tanks others have
different models there's not enough
interoperability it just soldier can't
sit in a tanker belonging to Germans so
it's it's not so much that the the
spending volumes it's what you spend the
money on and if this if the fondue line
report actually addresses this this
might be very good plus the economic
crisis may finally spur understand
correctly the dilemma then is not really
the state of the German Bundeswehr but
the lack of common European security
policy and the one of the fundamental
weaknesses of the current structure of
the European Union that there isn't
despite the rhetoric there isn't a
common defense policy because for many
reasons for nationalist reasons for
industry reasons because the real reason
is that it would lead to a European army
and this would underpin the national
sovereignty of the individual countries
of the EU and as long as we don't have
an integrated defense system the
European the European Union as the EU is
not going to go anywhere yeah if you
look at the larger actors in Europe the
Germans are reluctant for the reasons we
have already described the British
wouldn't want to be part of the European
army at all the French would like it but
only if it came from French so so but
still they have to move made efforts
made just to at least to although the
same equipment
and then we have tried the several times
the Eurofighter is called Eurofighter
because there many European nations
building this thing together but then if
it comes to the outfitting every
National Army said okay we want a
spoiler in on the back or we want this
and that different that that adds to the
costs immensely and we have to get rid
of this so there has at least to be an
understanding about the standards
perhaps not about the fighting or
targets but at least about the standards
of equipment that would help isn't it
interesting that with the economic
crisis with what's happening in the
Middle East with Ebola take any number
of conflicts now going around the world
isn't it interesting that one European
leader head of state had a couple to
stand up and say we have to prune our
resources there seems to be just
enormous reluctance to confront the
public with the weaknesses of the armed
forces throughout you I don't think that
is because because in leaders would have
to explain why do you have armed forces
forces defense for fighters defense
matter and successive defence ministers
and successive leaders absolutely
reluctant to do this fonder line is
touching on it there's one of the former
defence ministers who government of
conscription called here to sue
Guttenberg he started raising the issue
but the public isn't going to you're not
going to get the public on your side if
you don't explain why does defense
matter and the other question of course
Allison as Germany is in a bit of a
catch-22 isn't it of course people are
saying Germany has to spend more money
on military spending in order to fulfill
its obligation yet then again there
might be some countries out there that
you know that could rekindle some some
old fears no yes no I mean without
question and which is why Germany always
has to tread extra-specially carefully I
think it's pretty obvious to any serious
observer that there is no sort of
horrible jingoistic militarism ringing
through this government but that doesn't
mean to say that in general as was sort
of various specters of the past and you
were the one who mentioned Russia and
its aggressive new stance all sorts of
ghosts are kind of out there this year
particularly since it's 100
years since the start of World War one
and 75 since the start of World War two
and we'll be getting ready for a very
joyous 25th anniversary of the fall of
the Berlin Wall
but it's clouded all by a little doubt
but I think Judy's point is the
fundamental one for awfully long time
there hasn't really been a debate and
it's a very kind of arid debate to have
so it's not the kind of political issue
you can go on the hustings and gonna get
your voters whipped up about but it is
super serious to understand that you can
only be an actor on the world stage if
you have two things you have good
diplomacy and you have the sort of the
muscle behind that that you could deploy
if you needed to but as the world
becomes ever more diverse but
everybody's participating in everything
because we are globalized world now it's
going to be increasingly important for
governments to define what are they
going to use force for and what are they
not going to use it for and I think that
debate is certainly overdue the popular
excuse for German politicians asked
about this 2% target is in fact that if
we were to raise military spending to 2%
of our GDP it would amount to something
like 50 billion euros would be the
biggest defense budget in Europe by far
I mean at the moment we are do if you if
you just count out what French and
British spent on their nuclear
deterrence then the budgets are almost
leveled so the three big nations
spending roughly the same amount of
money if we were to increase this by
two-thirds
maybe other countries wouldn't be that
happy that's the one that's one side on
the other hand in this changed
surrounding political surroundings
especially these in European NATO
members are calling on Alice and saying
look are you really taking this NATO
thing seriously are you going to help us
to defend this Russian felt Russian
aggression and we we have to to back
this but I really say yeah yeah we we do
have the means and we have
invest in this means to be taken
seriously well I wonder about this I
think there's two two real tricky
questions here one is and coalition's of
the Willing are replacing NATO NATO is
not involved in eius and nature doesn't
want NATO you know will give will give
the tacit support of the Baltic States
but we've seen more and more coalition's
of the Willing coming into play at the
expense of a NATO collective solidarity
we saw this in Libya we were seeing it
now in irons and we've seen another
other missions secondly and I think the
Germans are beginning to address this
issue and one of the weaknesses of NATO
and the u.s. sees this very well that
the Europeans don't have a shared threat
perception the poles and the Baltics
Northern Europeans see Russia's their
threat you talk to the Portuguese the
Spaniards the Greeks Russian no no no no
no that the Spaniards the French the
British would see the Middle East and
North Africa as at rest so when you
don't have a common threat perception
it's very very difficult to decide how
you're going to treat Defence what
you're going to spend it on and how
you're going to explain to the public
for the threats are you're honest you
think these findings are even a blessing
in disguise perhaps because it is open
up the discussion perhaps German
citizens will start to take a second
look at the military and perhaps change
their attitude towards I think at least
you could say this report has still
stood up quite quite some interest in
Germany and that means at least the
military is taken more seriously now
than it has been five years ago so there
it's it's up to the politicians now to
make something of this and and to try to
increase public awareness and to find
ways to to to make the society aware of
how of their of the of Germany's
responsibility as the federal president
said we are one of the countries
exporting most Goods in the world we are
more alive we are more to rely on
outwards security than many other
countries and so this is the source of
our responsibility
the focus is now on the politician says
Johannes and of course the focus is very
much on the defense minister of
underline you could argue that's the way
she likes it she is of course rather
ambitious a lady who is even tapped to
become a possible successor to
Chancellor Merkel do you think this is
her make or break moment here well I
mean as I've just as I've pointed out
about defense ministers in Germany it's
it's a tricky position so she's in the
spotlight anybody who's in the spotlight
that faces more of a make-or-break
moment than somebody who isn't but I
think you know she's a very sort of
steady person it seems to me she works
through problems and main I mean I'm
sure the main thing is that she and the
Chancellor should be on the same page
she's attracted some degree of criticism
for posting of posing for rather fancy
pictures and people are saying stop I
really have to say that I think there's
a stream element of chauvinism in this
if men do it it's no problem
if women do it it's posing for oh gosh
she's trying to reach women as an
audience
shocking I mean I really objective this
independent pen is the Defence Minister
visiting the troops not photographed
frankly but this is a kind of an cynical
but it's very ambiguous someone to
revenge you know she needs a comeuppance
maybe she'll fail but it this goes back
to the role of Chancellor Merkel now
it's very very interesting if if if von
der Leyen succeeds Merkel was the
Chancellor Merkel can rightly say see I
choose the right person to run the
defense ministry if von der Leyen fails
well she tried you know but at the end
of the day we had the federal president
making speech Foreman's - making speech
about Germany's frontspin responsibility
in the defense minister we're still
waiting for Chancellor Merkel but we'll
wait forever because she'll just use
each stitch it shall judge each
situation as it comes only one oh by the
end of the show
visit we only have about 15 minutes but
Johannes again about the attitude of
Germans is it perhaps you know do do the
German people also have to start come
out of H I mean at the end of the day
yes of course Judy mentioned if we
scroll back to the 1990s when it was the
first time after the Second World War
that German fighter planes went to
another country and threw bombs and
actually went into combat that was in
Serbia and in the in the war about
Kosovo the the underlying arguments
displayed by the then foreign minister
Fischer was look this is the the
Auschwitz of our days so you had to
reach fairly high to find the supporter
- or to find a reason or course for
doing this we can't always just start
moving when it comes to genocide and
really the the world is totally into
shambles so we have to we have to maybe
come a step down and say look this is
the situation this is our possibilities
that's what we have to do so of course
this is the year where we celebrate 25
years of the wall coming down and again
it goes back to the question of what
Germany is what kind of country this
Germany want to be in the 21st century
it depends on who you ask of course but
what is interesting is that the
political elites are beginning to now
address this question before this public
opinion that drove it and the political
elites reacted but now you're getting a
slow change that the the political
elites be you know who who I mean
they're asking actually you know the
world is this is the 21st century it's
not just its interconnected that the
tracks are all around us and we cannot
isolate ourselves anymore and public
opinion yes you know we know you don't
like war but frankly Germany's the OP
new unique public opinions across Europe
don't like war most people don't like
war most people is not that the Germans
are inherently pacifist because of the
Second World War you can always hide
behind this but this is it this I go
back to this point is that there's a
weariness
the 25th anniversary is a moment
everything is coming together now the
the fonder lying case what's happening
in Africa what's happening in the Middle
East what's happening in Russia the old
predictable World Order is over not that
I was ever really predictable but went
to something new and also were into
something where even more than ever
these things are interrelated so is
produces all even greater flood of
refugees from Syria I was interested the
other day you had Finance Minister
Wolfgang schäuble saying we will not be
able to continue to handle the refugee
problem the way it's been handled we are
going to have to spend some money and
for instance in Africa if we still are
at a stage it would seem to me where if
we help Africans now we can foster more
of a middle class there more even more
than the economic growth there is
fostering anyway and people will want to
stay if we don't do it hello we should
we should get ready for a big influx of
people and then you have the other
elements as well German or European
jihadists going to Syria to fight
they're coming back
maybe steering unrest in our countries
and I think at the same time we are no
longer that much only defined by the
catastrophe of the second world war as a
nation other things come into play and
that that's that's quite interesting
again there's there's a task for
politicians here to change the outlook a
bit when when I was living in Great
Britain my impression was that this
country is entirely positive about
globalization they are always thinking
they can ride this tiger on their own
that's why they are so skeptic towards
the European Union whereas the mood in
in Germany is totally different we are
passive it's something massive out there
we don't like it within we are unsecure
what will happen a bit more like the
French so we have to change this
attitude the person that tried to change
this was one of the former presidents
Horst köhler who was former head of the
International Monetary Fund and when he
was president of Germany he gave
interview actually explaining that the
the the anti-piracy mission of the coast
of of the Horn of Africa was there to
protect German commercial interests and
how do anybody mention this that Armed
Forces and German commercial interest
have a connection and what happens he
was forced to resign media pressure the
hypocrisy of the media and now president
Gul can actually say these things openly
our interests are just not here they're
just not in the Middle East they're on
the commercial sailing channels trading
channels that affect the German economy
that affect a European economy that
affect the world economy and so finally
the debates about defense and security
is becoming tangible it's not about
old-fashioned tanks and bombardments
it's about the security of energy
supplies it's about the security of
borders it's about the security of
infrastructure and this is a very good
thing that this debate is oh no I mean
security has become you've got for
instance the refugee question I mean as
we celebrate the 25th anniversary what
was 1989 which Judy and I spent so much
time together during that year it was
about the movement of people and now we
have people trying to move out of the
Middle East and out of Africa because
conditions there are frankly unbearable
and conditions here are better and if we
really take the message of 89 as this
was people striving for a better life
and v as in does fork so why are we not
going to listen to this from plenty of
other people in a globalized world I
don't see how we avoid that and again
that's the message you can you can have
in with regard to Ukraine as well and
there's there's a task and
responsibility for us I think yeah I
think I mean Ukraine we've hardly
mentioned here but it's it's for Germany
very big security issue and at the
moment was you know the suggestion is
that there's still a way to solve this I
haven't heard too much mention of the
bill because I don't understand where
the money's coming from
another bill we would have to fit and
that would be larger than any military
equipment if we might want procure and I
mean this finding we cannot ignore
Germany cannot ignore it the politician
certainly cannot ignore it if you were
was enough on the lines advisor what
would what would you advise her what
well what would she would have to do to
bring the German military back up to
shape
I'm totally content with my role as a
bystander but if I were to advise her I
would say go for your European
cooperation but on very very common
standards don't do any extras even again
and they are they are tentatively
starting this there have been some
agreements on the recent NATO summit
smaller countries are getting this
message quicker than we do there's the
Dutch and the Danish and others they are
they are quite eager to cooperate with
the larger countries getting or sharing
parts of their armies I think the Dutch
have got rid of all their fighter planes
and putting them under Belgian command
whereas the Belgian Navy has been put
under the Dutch command so these are
models we can we can pursue there's a
great portion in Germany to make it make
a big issue out of something and then
you forget about now something else to
replace it I think perhaps underlines
underline herself and her advisors would
be well-placed not to let this issue
disappear keep it on the agenda widen
the debates make it accessible explain
what is happening this is the time now
to excuse the military term go on the
offensive again I too will contend with
my role as bystander but I think a
combination of these two points Germany
has actually an opportunity perhaps to
lead because indeed Britain and France
are in a different Club they have a
nuclear deterrent and they have much
more robust attitude towards the use of
military force just from evolving from
their history and so on but the new game
eebee to cooperate more and Germany
could become the sort of the umbrella
force for that and use its influence and
its money to push things forward I mean
if indeed even if the percentage went up
to let's say 1.7 percent of GDP there
would be several billion more euros
available and perhaps that's the thing
to think about how would we spend those
in forging a more common European since
we are running out of time I do want to
get bits specific here once again you're
honest about the two conflicts that are
obviously have kept this occupied for a
better part of this year in the Ukraine
and also the fight against Isis let's
start with Isis let's start with
northern Iraq the Germans have after a
long debate agreed to supply courage
with weapons in northern Iraq do you
foresee a role beyond that for Germany
and I think there will be a larger role
we probably will not five
join this air striking company but we
will do exercise exercising Iraqi troops
on the ground I think and what about
Ukraine let's talk about Ukraine here
because that obviously hits a home
gemonese role here
I mean we know that Chancellor Merkel
has been engaging in a very active
telephone diplomacy with President Putin
what do you see militarily Germany
militarily Germany can do very little
and NATO could do very little also maybe
some training but Ukraine isn't a NATO
and it's not going to be a member of
nation the foreseeable future
and chance Chancellor Merkel is in a
terrible bind and she's the interlocutor
with Putin but we see on front of us
happening right now the creation of a
frozen conflict in eastern Ukraine and a
buffer zone being carved out and whether
or not Chancellor Merkel and some of our
analysts are strong enough to actually
prevent this from happening it's going
to be very difficult and one final point
a frozen conflict means that this
potential instability in Ukraine for
such a long time that the idea of
pushing through reforms would be very
difficult so obviously we're not hoping
for a military conflict here
you know but but if push comes to show
the Germany's role here
well Germany's role here is going to
evolve and it's going to be still
constant engagement I mean the only way
to keep this issue adaptable is to keep
it on the table very very firmly so I
mean and you have to sort of
differentiate I think between say short
term goals I mean at the moment I think
the the minds are concentrated on the
European Asian meeting next week in
Italy where it's hoped that poroshenko
the Ukrainian president will meet Putin
the Russian president you know that's
the talk we shall see is that what is
that the short term goal but clearly
you've got to keep people talking the
difficulty is as Judy rightly points out
if you have a frozen conflict you have
built-in instability and basically
Russia has shown as its as the rebel
forces in the East were on the verge of
losing most of their territory at the
end of August Russia weighed in with
more help and basically said we're
always willing to put our finger on the
scale to make the outcome take us into
account and the question is is that
going to be so destructive that you
really can't do anything or is it a way
of saying we've got to be at the table
let's go back a little bit we can have a
long argument about whether Russia was
sufficiently informed of Ukraine's
willingness to the association agreement
and so on yeah I think for the long term
there's only hope there there is no no
proof of a concept working but in the
long term I think what the European
Union's is ankhor could be aiming at is
to make Ukraine or the stable part we've
created an economic success and
therefore showing Russia it's on the
wrong path that's the other that's hard
to do when state well long term there
they are no quick fix this year that's
for sure and I think the same goes for
state of the German military which have
to be reformed in some shape or another
I want to thank my guests for a very
insightful talk about European security
policy but also of course about the
state of the German military as is today
well thank you out there for tuning in
and looking forward to seeing you again
next week for a new edition of quadriga